well much to the surprise of basically
no one we now have learned that no
Donald Trump has no tapes of his oval
office meeting with fired FBI director
James Comey there were always I I say
two main possibilities really probably
three or four but other than Trump
actually made the recordings there were
a couple of possibilities one was maybe
Donald Trump thought that James Comey
made some recordings and he wanted to
try to draw it out of him or Donald
Trump claimed to maybe have recordings
of his oval office meeting with James
Comey to scare Comey
with the idea that you'd better tell the
truth Jim because otherwise I have
recordings that would prove you wrong
well Donald Trump announced in a sort of
- tweet message that he doesn't have
recordings of his meeting with James
Comey starting out with tweet number one
where he said with all of the recently
reported electronic surveillance
intercepts unmasking and illegal leaking
of information I have no idea whether
there are tapes or recordings of my
conversations with James Comey but I did
not make and do not have any such
recordings now some people looked at
this with a very very micro eye and they
said listen what Trump is saying is he
didn't make the recordings maybe
somebody else set up the recording
devices and that he doesn't have the
recordings maybe the person who set up
the recording device has the recording
so Donald Trump could be using really
really specific language to make it seem
as though there are no recordings but
he's just saying he's not the guy who
sat there with a recording device and
now has those quote tapes I think the
most likely scenario is there were never
any tapes and there are no tapes and
Trump doesn't have them and nobody else
does here is Donald Trump being asked
about this on Fox News Fox News
basically congratulate the guy for lying
public publicly saying hey this was
really a great way to make sure that
James Comey didn't lie but when he found
out that I you know that there may be
tapes out there whether it's
governmental tapes or anything else and
who knows
I think his story may have changed and
I'll have to take a look at that because
then he has to tell what actually took
place at the events and my story didn't
change my story was always a straight
story my story was always the truth but
you have to determine for yourself
whether or not his story changed but I
did not take there's a smart way to make
sure he stayed honest and as hearing
well it wasn't it wasn't very stupid I
can tell you this is hilarious on a
number of levels number one there is no
you know kept Co me honest by suggesting
there might be tapes there's no evidence
whatsoever that James commis story
changed at all as a result of the
possibility of tapes that's number one
there's no evidence of that whatsoever
but number two commis testimony was
hugely damaging to trump dramatically
damaging to trump so how is this even oh
oh it was such a smart way to make sure
he stayed honest if you believe that the
possibility of tapes kept Co me honest
then you must believe he told the truth
when he testified and the truth is
insanely damaging so I don't even know
how this is the victory that the Fox
News interviewer and Trump are sort of
pretending that this is well the whole
reason in the first place that Trump
floated this idea that there might be
tapes was to have some leverage over
James Comey right but it completely
backfired because if there were tapes
then they could be subpoenaed or
potentially more tapes than just the
Comey meetings and then if there were in
case then we get into a conversation
about potential witness tampering and
intimidation so ya know in here there's
no art of the deal there's an argument
to be made and not being a lawyer and
and feeling like it's sort of irrelevant
because we're never going to see
anything happen as a result of it you
could make the argument that making
false statements in order to try to
impact the testimony of a public
official that's colloquially a form of
obstruction of justice because that is
part of an investigation but there's a
sort of other funny element to this
which is by sort of appealing to Trump's
desire to seem smart the Fox News
interviewer got Trump to admit that hey
it was pretty smart of me to suggest
that there were tapes when there
it wasn't stupid because it got Comey to
quote be honest what would happen if a
reporter went to trump and posed a
question like mr. president many people
say there's no way that you would be
smart enough to orchestrate Russian
meddling in the election so I'm sure
you're innocent right you're simply not
smart enough to orchestrate something
like that
I wonder if Trump desire to appear smart
would get him to say no no listen I am
plenty smart enough to collude with
Russia and that's exactly what you're
going to be finding out about soon it is
interesting how the Fox News reporters
question was like the easiest of all
time such a under head and meatball
throne - yeah and he still managed to
strike out on it yet with this just
bizarre unintelligible explanation about
well it wasn't stupid and it got him to
stay honest the blah blah blah just
bizarre and listen nobody's surprised
about this but this has been very
successful at getting the attention off
of Trump for Obama wiretapped me
nobody's talking about what Obama
wiretapped me now because the entire
okoma better hope there aren't tapes
thing has now become the bigger
controversy it is controversy to
describe distracts from line to distract
from idiocy that that's basically the mo
of Donald Trump